foreign
[Music]
what do you do to add volume to your
hair oh first of all not all of us are
born with great thick hair that has a
lot of volume like me most of you
realize that I have very thin hair
so to add volume to my hair
listen up this is what I do
first when I need to style my hair I
make it wet with lukewarm water
second I use volumizing mousse or sea
salt spray and I run it through my hair
three I take my hair dryer and I make
sure it's not on the hot setting and
then I start to blow my hair I will
slowly blow my hair by lifting it up and
blowing it into the style I want another
great tip especially if you don't have a
lot of time is to blow it upside down I
always do this when I'm in a hurry it
really works well to add volume to your
hair
and lastly I just add my favorite hair
Pomade American Crew to style it a bit
better
and sometimes I would use just a little
bit of hairspray so that my hair will
stay in place
now just a bonus tip start to use
volumizing shampoo and conditioner for
your hair as well I will add all the
products I personally like in the video
description for you to check out now if
you want to check out my personal
skincare routine check out this video
here and I'll see you there and before
you go always remember life is short so
don't waste yours cheers guys